you've probably seen the private
security footage that helped find the
Boston Marathon terrorism suspects the
images show the value cameras play in
fighting terrorism thanks to
surveillance cameras the FBI was able to
plaster airwaves with a video Most
Wanted poster of the Boston bombing
suspects law enforcement leaders and
politicians have even called for more
city cameras on street corners it's
there a great law or enforcement method
and device I'm a major proponent of of
cameras more cameras the better and I
think the privacy issue is you know
really been taken off the table cameras
in the hands of government proposing
very different threat to privacy staff
attorney Peter b-bring of the ACLU of
Southern California says that there's a
big difference between private security
footage like the kind used to catch the
Boston terror suspects and cameras run
by the government government has the
power to investigate prosecute and
potentially jail people and that's a
very different thing from doing what
officers did in Boston which is
responding to a known crime by reviewing
existing footage there the footage came
from private individuals and store
surveillance cameras still when it comes
to fighting terrorism why wouldn't we
want more police eyes on the street a
camera just makes it more sophisticated
but it's no different from your neighbor
looking out the window at you or police
officer looking at you're walking down
the street actually because of
technology today city cameras may be
more sophisticated than you think
b-bring describe to us what a city
network of cameras might look like a
centrally networked system of cameras
that can monitor people throughout the
city that can compare information camera
to camera that can warehouse in one
central location weeks or years of
footage and potentially scan it for
individuals through facial recognition
technology and that technology is
expanding quickly these cameras can even
pick suspects out of a crowd based on
the shirt they're wearing
it's called artificial intelligence
software that turns surveillance cameras
into smart cameras so smart the computer
learns what normal they
a viewer looks like on every corner and
can spot abnormalities instantly from
abandoned packages to suspicious
activity alerting police in real-time
but in order to do that they have to
keep a record of the activities not only
of criminals but of the lawful
activities of law-abiding citizens for
weeks and months and years just in case
it ever becomes useful and the privacy
concern isn't so much the images of you
it's the information about you that's
gathered from those images people don't
have a privacy interest against being
seen on a public street but the Supreme
Court has recognized that they do have a
privacy interest in being having their
location tracked over time so
technologies like surveillance cameras
that could potentially track a person's
location while they're engaged in
ordinary lawful activities over a whole
city those do pose privacy concerns that
are much different than simply being
photographed in one place the question
with surveillance cameras as with any
surveillance tool is really what is the
right balance between our core values of
security and privacy and that's why when
law enforcement uses surveillance
cameras or any other surveillance tool a
public discussion and a written privacy
policy or important safeguards to have I
think the simple fact is that too many
of these technologies get adopted by
police departments without a lot of
public discussion and so few departments
have good privacy policies for the kinds
of new surveillance technologies that
we're talking about I think the problem
that we're seeing now is the technology
is evolving so quickly and there are so
many new ways for police to listen to
communications to monitor people's
location to get information about us
that the law is just not keeping up in
addressing what the right answer is